[Musique]
doit-on défend de ses amis à tout prix
c'est une question qu'on est en droit de
se poser au vu des nombreuses affaires
d'agression sexuelle concernant ppda
richard berry ou plus récemment harry
habitants ary abittan été placé en garde
à vue a été mis en examen certains
proches prennent la parole dans les
médias et se fond l'avocat du diable
pour tenter de défendre ceux qui sont
pourtant présumé innocent mais jugé trop
vite à travers le prisme des médias on
se souvient de michel polacco qui était
venu prendre la défense de son ami ppda
sur notre plateau en février dernier je
trouve qu'il est dommage qu'on puisse
faire d'abord le procès médiatique rue
avant que l'instruction la vraie est eu
lieu ou encore alexandre arcady qui
s'était exprimé au sujet de la sphère
bérisson ses news c'est quelqu'un qui
est incapable d'une action comme celle
là plus récemment encore c'est bernard
montiel qui a été la cible de nombreuses
insultes sur les réseaux sociaux pour
avoir pris la défense d'harry habitants
jusqu'au bout je le défendrai temps
qu'on m'a pas prouvé le contraire mais
vous qu'auriez vous fait à leur place
doit-on défendre ses amis à tout prix
ça c'est un sujet qui fait énormément
réagir un déjà là sur les réseaux et les
21 26 on est en direct et mon ami yann
moix est avec nous ce soir écrivain et
chroniqueur je suis très heureux qu'il
fasse partie bien sûr de mes équipes
merci yann d'être là ce soir et c'est
vrai que toi aussi tu as vécu une
tornade médiatique un moment c'est vrai
que on s'est dit et on n'en a pas parlé
souvent tous les deux c'est vrai qu'on
se sent bien seul dans ces moments là
disons que le 21e siècle a une
particularité c'est que au 20e siècle on
avait 12 ou aujourd'hui on a toujours le
who's who mais c'est un who's who ou
malveillance et vous ou de laine c'est
une très mauvaise nouvelle très mauvaise
nouvelle c'est que tout ce qui passe à
la télé même si pour présenter les
chiffres et les lettres où la météo
auront une polémique un jour c'est celle
mauvaise nouvelle la bonne c'est que un
mois deux mois trois mois plus tard il
n'en restera rien c'est ça aussi le 21e
siècle mais il est vrai que lorsque la
tourmente et là que vous avez des chiens
aux basques avant que les mouches ne
changent d'âne et bien vous regardez
dans votre calepin qui sont les amis qui
reste j'ai eu beaucoup de chance je dois
le dire non seulement aucun ami ne m'a
manqué
les amis en fait c'est comme le vin
pluies sont vieux puits sont solides
mais je m'en suis fait des nouveaux dont
vous par exemple cirysiens et donc c'est
vrai que c'est d'une violence inouïe
dans l'impression d'être dans un un
lavomatic à l'intérieur à la place du
linge et ça secoue et ça secoue on
allume la télévision voit sa tête on
allume la radio on entend son nom alors
évidemment les gens qui
s'immisce dans ce brouhaha et qui vous
disent tu es mon ami je t'aime en fera
de la télévision comme vous d'autres qui
sont toujours fidèles au rendez vous on
s'aperçoit d'une certaine manière que ça
n'a pas de prix amitié et c'est quelque
chose dont on se rend pas compte tant
qu'on n'a pas éprouvé alain delon disait
que l'amitié ça consistait à vérifier si
un ami si quelqu'un pouvait cacher le
cadavre que vous veniez de cesser de
faire à 4 heures du matin oui c'est ça
l'amitié quand bernard défend l'un de
ses amis bien sûr il a mille fois raison
tant mêmes mais je vais même beaucoup
plus loin si c'est son ami et qu'il a
véritablement comme isc qu'on l'accuse
d'avoir commis ce qu'il faut être
d'ailleurs très prudent avant de dire
bernard tout à fait raison de dire oui
ben son amitié je la conserverai mon
amitié on ne choisit pas les amis en
fonction de la morale c'est la morale
n'a rien à voir avec l'amitié la mitis
est quelque chose qui échappe à tous les
registres il ya quelque chose parce que
c'était lui parce que c'était moi c'est
très rationnel
beaucoup d'amis enfin qu'il fût croyez
tes amis quittent ont tourné le dos non
plus non pas du tout le seul ami qui m'a
tourné le dos j'ai appris qu'en fait il
était dans la tourmente il a déclenché
cette tourmente avec mon frère donc en
fait oui voilà c'est ça c'était pas vrai
n'hésitez pas un ami c'est un traître
voilà exactement non qu aucun aucun
aucun après on a des plus ou moins
courageuse des requins qui attendent 24
heures aux 44 ans de 48 heures mais ça
c'est humain après il se rattrape mais
il faut la garder l'espoir toujours oui
mais parce que ben quand tu étais veut
dire que bon honnêtement il ya quelque
chose de terrible dans ces cas là c'est
qu'on se demande véritablement si ce qui
nous arrive est vrai c'est irréel les
hommes politiques sont habitués à voir
ça les hommes d'état les hommes publics
mais un écrivain un artiste un acteur le
présentateur on n'est pas fait pour ça a
priori est ce qui vous si vous voulez
dans mon cas il y avait un truc terrible
j'avais fait ces caricatures il ya
trente ans mais il ya quelque chose
d'horrible dans mon cas précis c'est que
quand bien même ces bandes dessinées et
est abject et
ni si elles étaient
si vous voulez y avait précédé
prescrites par la loi or le système
médiatique a décidé que la prescription
n'existait pas c'est à dire plutôt que
de dire quand même ce type il aurait pu
devenir fasciste avec la famille
l'extrême droite qui l'avait plutôt que
de regarder le parcours que j'avais fait
était le contraire de ce que j'avais été
programmé pour être on a préféré me
ramener dans une case 30 ans en arrière
alors que toute la journée on fait
l'apologie des gens dans les banlieues
etc mais pas dans les banlieues qui
partent de rien et qui arrive à s'élever
de manière contraire aux idéaux qu'ils
avaient reçu à la base il ya plutôt que
de dire [ __ ] ce mec il a évolué on m'a
remis 30 ans en arrière ça pour me
résigner à ce que j'avais failli devenir
et donc mes amis étant intelligent pour
la plupart ils les est bien choisi et
peut-être qu'ils m'ont moins bien
choisis que moi je les ai choisis et
bien ils n'ont pas été dupes voyez ce
que je veux dire à un moment tu t'es dit
je vais tout lâcher je vais arrêter je
vais je sais que tu avais pris un petit
peu de recul tu étais parti un petit peu
au tir il je vais pas je sais que vous
êtes très pudique je dois dire qu'il ya
deux personnes qui m'ont tenu à bout de
bras eric naulleau et vous parmi les
nouveaux amis de monsieur est pour moi
l'aspect professionnel étant extrêmement
important je jure régulièrement de vos
nouvelles je vais pas venir ici pour
vous irez les points dangereux j'ai eu
des nouvelles régulièrement un petit mot
de temps en temps vous aviez un radar
donc vous savez très bien vous avez
réussi à sentir les mouvements de
terrain et quand vous m'avez dit toute
façon ça passera et tu nous rejoindra
bientôt cette perspective
professionnelle m'a fait énormément de
bien parce que c'est bien de partir avec
des bouquins et sa guitare au bout du
monde enfin si une petite voix qui vous
dit tu en feras de la télévision chose
qui pour moi est très important que vous
ne savez ça change tout et sa cible et
les amis parlent peu mais ils agissent
c'est comme un amour cocteau disais en
amour il n'y a pas de parole il ya des
actes en amitié aussi
[Applaudissements]
alors bernard
donc je sais que ça faisait un petit peu
ça faisait un petit peu attristé ce qui
vous est arrivé c'est le dernier jour
sur les réseaux tout seul je sais que
oui j'étais sûr plus encore aujourd'hui
mais si vous voulez je défends mon
amitié avec avec harry c'est un ami je
lui resterait fidèle mais ce que je
défends surtout c'est la présomption
d'innocence évidemment sur sert d'abord
comment on condamne les gens on ne sait
pas moi j'ai jamais dit que je savais et
on ne sait pas personne ne sait on a vu
tous les grands dit dans les journaux on
ne sait pas donc c'est ça que je défends
c'est la présomption d'innocence et là
mais maintenant on me met carrément
bernard montiel hashtag culture du viol
s'il ya un paquet de tarés h et la
culture de l'amitié
je sais que ça touche et vous demandez
encore parler de talent évidemment que
c'est toujours parce que en plus il ya
quelques artistes qui me me rentrer
dedans qu'ils rentrent dans la meute je
suis un peu charrié certaines artistes
oui bah oui alors alors il ya un truc
sommes hallucinantes qu'on m'a ressorti
je vais quand même le dire
ces années 80 quand je présentais la une
est à vous j'ai reçu la maman de izia
higelin et quand une femme absolument
ravissante vous allez voir ce qui s'est
passé exactement
c'est sur les vidéos donc c'est facile à
retrouver jeudi à cette jeune femme
ravissante jeudi excusez moi je suis
troublé vous êtes très belle et vous
avez un beau décolleté point
culture du viol c'était déjà un gros
lourdaud et c est alors hashtag et les
gens qui ont suivi derrière choqué c'est
des gens que j'aime bien barbara prat
vie je le dis juliette armanet que
j'adore qui est une grande artiste qui
qui met du baume ils le faisaient les
mots je sais je suis choqué d'où ça sort
parce que tu dis à quelqu'un qu'elle est
belle ça c'est une vieille vidéo en plus
des années 80 bien sûr le chercheur au
sommet tu vois c'est incroyable la
définition de l'eau potable a changé
donc l'eau qu'on pouvait boire en 1982
est devenue invivable aujourd'hui c'est
tout mais il se trouve quand même que
dans ses mouvements et des choses très
positives c'est aussi pour ça que des
gros plans avec plus dé main au cul et
donc la génération mais ces exagérations
font partie de l'évolution dans un
temporaire mans on a besoin de ces
exagérations sinon la société n'évoluera
jamais mais bien sûr il ya des victimes
collatérales et bien sûr mais j'ai même
pas envie vous savez aussi que je
travaille avec la fondation des femmes
qui luttent quand même contre les
violences faites aux femmes depuis des
années je suis obligé de le dire
tellement je reçois des mots mais des
insultes graves tu n'es pas content
admettons je parle pas des habitants
admettons que tu es un ami réellement
violé quelqu'un qui te contamine pas par
son action jeune fille n'est pas
contaminé par l'action de quelqu'un à la
maison mais
je papier j'ai dû tout bernard mais la
question jens et la présomption
d'innocence est effectivement sans qu'on
n'a pas la preuve que ton ami a fait
quelque chose tu arrêtes ton ami mais
même en revanche là où moi je te rejoins
tout petit mois plus j'apprends qu'en
revanche mon ami c'est lui je crois et
mon ami avait rejoint ma dose vraiment
violé les normes la selo je te rejoins
pas jamais peut-être détourner mon
analyse sur un archonte eux conservera
son amitié pour harry si les fesses et
ainsi construire je les 10 heures je me
dis que je lui ai donné mon amitié c'est
un ami et c'est pour ça que j'ai dit je
ne veux pas y croire je ne veux pas en
revanche si je suis trahi
qu'effectivement il a commis ça c'est
sûr que c'est autre chose alors que
j'avais donné l'exemple d'alain delon
était que de manière inconditionnelle il
faut défendre son ami sauf s'il ya
trahison sa fille rétroactivement du tu
aperçois qu il a fait un acte qui trahit
l'amitié qui trahit la confiance
non parce qu'il est chaud il ya des
choses qui me semble moins grave que
d'autres accueillent le cas d'un viol
c'est un absolu maintenant le cas de mes
dessins pour moi n'était pas un objet
d'un vol mais ça le travail de
reconstruction on peut rester à ses
côtés pour l'aider enfin la dépense qui
l'a fait venir est le travail de
reconstruction
mais j'écoute également que ça à chaque
fois parce qu'il a beaucoup voilà il a
énormément de brio et talent mais moi
effectivement c'était il y avait une
petite ambiguïté non il n'a pas à dire
j'ai trouvé et battu à trouver et
valérie à trouver des cabines petit ange
et lever cette ambiguïté il ya des
choses qui sont imprescriptibles
effectivement absolue mon ami je
découvre que c'est un pédocriminels on
si c'est un violeur récidiviste
effectivement j'ai du mal et je me dis
moi même que j'ai été trahi trahison du
doigt on va détourner ça veut dire que
ça n'a jamais été un ami parce qu'il en
a jamais parlé donc germé dans les
chambres à coucher des deux de ses neuf
mois si moi aussi c'est avant tout le
temps ça peut littéralement
castaldi non mais il a raison on
absolument tout dit aussi j'ai un ami
mais mon meilleur ami c'est l'effet une
chose qui me semble qu'on consacre
répréhensible à balayer quelques
quelques tamouls b2 fini le bio le
terrain ce sera impossible pour moi de
regarder comme ami après le défendre
avant de savoir évidemment qu'il faut
défendre son ami à tout prix évidemment
évidemment tant qu'on ne sait pas après
c'est quand il ya les preuves et les
faits c'est
tellement bafoués c'est incroyable c'est
choquant mais en tout cas parler de moi
que ça merci de cette invitation